prime minister thank you very much
indeed for agreeing to see me here in
London good to see you it's been uh 10
years it has been 10 years since I came
to Jerusalem yeah a lot of things have
happened a lot has changed a lot has
changed not least where I'm working
well I'm still working this yeah exactly
um I promise you've been elected six
times
you're the longest serving prime
minister in Israel's history 15 years
Israel is 75 in a few weeks time and it
ought to be a time a celebration both
for you for this extraordinary Personal
Achievement and for your country but
instead Israel is in turmoil at the
moment facing what some fear could turn
out to be civil war fears of a potential
third interfada
is this your biggest challenge right now
it's a very big challenge but I I think
that the prospects for Israel are great
I think there is a lot of concern about
the Democratic judicial reform that we
want to move ahead with
but people think that it's going to uh
uh to result in a fissure that I don't
think will last because people will see
at the end that Israel was a democracy
is a democracy and will be even a
stronger democracy after this democratic
reform so I think I think you're right
there's a lot of tension right now I and
I wish it wasn't so but I'm quite
confident that we'll get over this uh
this difficulty because you know you
have to reform things that get ossified
and in Israel what we've had is a the
ossification of the the the imbalance
between the three branches of government
that has to be corrected this happened
in the last 20 years it's been building
up building up building up and people
say we want to correct that and you know
people who are used to one thing don't
want to correct itself well that's
because the the critics say it's not
reform it's regime change effective is
what you're trying to push through they
say that what this bill will do it'll
arm you the prime minister with the
power to appoint judges that you want
and for your government to overturn any
Judgment of the Supreme Court that you
don't like someone says even a one vote
majority in the knesset in other words
the Judiciary they say will be neutered
and with that the rule of law and with
that democracy itself yeah well let's
take that apart one by one the first
thing that that has to be understood is
what is a democracy democracy is a
majority rule with a protection of
individual rights and to get these two
things what you have is the checks and
balances between the three branches of
government the legislative the executive
and the judicial everybody understands
that in Israel over the last 20 years
that balance has been uh taken off the
rails because the Judiciary became not
independent it's always been independent
will always be independent it became
all-powerful so it can nullify any
decision of the parliament the knesset
and it could be a legal decision a legal
uh law that's fine but they say it's not
reasonable it doesn't exist anywhere in
the Democracy such Powers it can nullify
any decision of the government and often
has it can nullify any appointment of
the government it can intervene in
military matters it can intervene in our
battle against terrorists it can
intervene in taking gas out of the sea
that causes billions of dollars billions
of dollars I finally got it out all
these things are unacceptable but it's
cool hang on it's called checks and
balances well there is no checks and
balances but the only well actually it's
the only checking balance in Israel to
the government no no it's not in in all
democracies there's one other thing and
I'll get I'll answer your question one
by one it's important there's one other
thing that characterizes this uh the the
the Judiciary in Israel and that is that
the judges veto the appointment of
Judges they effectively select
themselves in other words that doesn't
exist in any democracy the reform that
we're dealing with right now corrects
that it allows for a balance well it
means that you can pick them no no I
can't pick them in fact it's it's it's
an even thing between the majority and
the minority the Coalition and the
opposition uh it's in in fact not that
one side can pick them but by the way in
most democracies with the exception of
Britain by the way they all all judges
are chosen by elected officials and in
Israel the discussion is so uh narrow
and so one-sided they say how could it
be the judges will be chosen by elected
officials and I say hello this is what
is being done in every democracy why why
is someone like you who's always been
such a staunch defender of an
independent Judiciary in Israel why take
a move that even some of your close
colleagues and supporters say is a step
too far in infringing on that
Independence I absolutely will always
defend the independence of the Judiciary
and the way that's achieved in all the
democracies who are in which judges are
appointed by elected officials in
America in America for example uh who
picks the judges the politicians the
president the politicians then have to
affirm by the way that's replicated more
or less in most of the democracies in
one way or the other well how do how are
the judges independent they're
independent because once they're there
they're there either until retirement or
until life and that's what happened in
the United States just now I mean the
former president chose some very strong
conservative judges and the first
opportunity they're voted against them
because they're independent so the
independence of the Judiciary will
always be maintained I think that the
important thing to us that's not that's
not how people are seeing this because
they don't know the facts well they
studied the bill and they say they're
presenting it as an autocratic move no
well they're framing it as such but they
haven't really studied them but is what
you're doing really consistent with what
you said in 2002 yes in the speech I
mean remind you your exact words then I
believe that a strong independent court
allows for the existence of all other
institutions in a democracy I ask that
you show me one dick dictatorship one
undemocratic Society were a strong
independent court system exists there's
no such thing in places with no strong
independent court system rights cannot
be protected in fact the difference
between countries in which rights are
only on paper and those in which there
are actual rights that difference is a
strong independent Court this is the
reason that I am doing and will continue
to do everything I can to protect the
court system and make it strong and
independent I will continue to operate
this way every time a bill comes across
my desk that could harm the independence
of Israeli courts will take it off the
table that's you 2012. and now here you
are 11 years later you're the one
putting the bill on the table which many
people on all sides of the divide in
Israel say is achieving the exact thing
you were so Keen to avoid I stand by
everything that I said an independent
Court in a Judiciary that is independent
is something that was in Israel and will
remain in Israel but here's the thing in
the last 10 years
the Judiciary went from being an
independent Judiciary to an all-powerful
Judiciary the balance of three the three
branches of government says that you
have to have three branches that are
balanced in Israel you have like one big
trunk the Judiciary that's what's
developed with two little Twigs on the
side that's not democracy democracy
means that every every branch of
government balances the other and that's
in Israel it's the most judicially
activist court on the planet people
would rather in Israel it seems judging
by these Mass protests hundreds of
thousands of people out on the streets
protesting every weekend now for nearly
three months you've got General Scholars
entrepreneurs former heads of Mossad
some of your closest political allies
have come out and attacked this and said
this is a Judicial coup made by the
majority in order to grab power away and
not give Israelis the Protections in law
they're entitled to reservist fighter
pilots refused to attend a training
exercise this week joined by 650 members
of the I IDF Special Forces command this
is Uncharted Territory for Israel and
you've got Army general staff senior
military officials who believe this is
now imperiling the security of Israel
and you've always positioned yourself I
know this because you've told me
yourself before as Israel's Mr security
well let's let's again if you'd allow me
to answer the question of course okay so
the first thing is I think balancing the
judicial uh having the judges not select
themselves which is what this bill is
about is not only does not only uh
weaken democracy it strengthens
democracy because in all other
democracies and all other democracies
with the exception of the UK and there
may be one more exception the judges do
not choose themselves the elected
officials do and that's what this bill
does and I think it's right on the other
hand there is one consideration that the
critics and the opponents of this
judicial reform uh uh raise and I think
it's a valid concern and that is you
want to go from one extreme to the
center you don't you don't want the
pendulum to swing to the other side
where the us at our Parliament can
nullify any decision of the Supreme
Court and I think that requires a
balance I agree with that so it has to
be so you are going to rain back then on
this course propose yes I said that how
significantly well I said that there's
not going to be uh this unlimited power
when you want to restrain unlimited
power you don't go and give the
parliament unlimited power over the
court that's what they say this
currently does I explained very clearly
that as far as I'm concerned that will
not happen so I think you need to reach
the the happy center now the other thing
is look I don't want the Army you know
look
I think a lot of people go to these
demonstrations they're patriotic
Israelis they want the good of the
country but a lot of them don't actually
know the details of the bills just like
I just described they don't even know
that the leaders of the opposition that
are now going to these demonstrations
they themselves argue that the court the
way we select judges should be changed
they themselves did it before the
election all these people protesting
just don't get it many many of them
don't many of them it's not slightly
patronizing prime minister no I don't
think to tell your own people who are
protesting in hundreds I didn't say that
all of them don't I mean they just don't
understand well listen you have to see
the mainstream media in Israel that is
going on this like a huge huge huge
propaganda campaign well the added
complication for you is that you of
course are still going through an
ongoing trial that is suspended while
you're prime minister for corruption and
bribery not suspended at all it's going
on all the time so it's going on it's
going on and in fact it's unraveling the
charges the uh the main the charges that
were put before me were ridiculous and
they're just unraveling in the court
you're discovering things like
prosecutorial intimidation of witnesses
the blackmailing of witnesses changing
uh tampering with them but here's the
point so all of that is coming out and
brother you would agree it would be
dealt with in the trial the judges that
are going to decide this case have
already been selected they will not be
affected here's the point I was going to
make is twofold one the Attorney General
Gali baharav miara says you broken the
law by directly involving yourself in an
overhaul of the Judiciary when you're
facing an ongoing corruption trial she
said it was illegal and tainted by
conflict of interest that's completely
false I maintained the same conflict of
interest restraints and I'm abiding by
every consideration that my case is not
going to be affected by this legal
reform what happened to insist I'm the
prime minister of Israel Israel is going
through the most acute crisis in many
years
uh you yourself said how important it is
to say that the prime minister of Israel
cannot deal with something to try to
bring a resolution to this crisis cannot
speak about it cannot try to resolve
this issue cannot take care of the
security of the country which you
yourself say maybe uh maybe uh impacted
by this this is this is absurd if it was
a if it was an opposition leader who was
in power who was going through a
corruption and bribery trial I don't
think you'd have the same view I think
you would say that you'd say there's a
clear conflict of interest here I'd say
no there isn't because the trial or my
legal proceedings are completely
unaffected by the this so the Attorney
General I mean if if the statement is
that you've broken the law you're saying
as prime minister of Israel the Attorney
General's wrong about the law of course
I'm saying it I said it openly and it's
not a question we have a disagreement on
that in fact that's going to be brought
up uh in court proceedings I think it's
wrong I think I as prime minister Israel
have a responsibility to see if I can
somehow bring a conclusion to this
impasse somehow bring a resolution so we
have responsible judicial democratic
reform and at the same time Keep the
Country together who's going to do that
if not the Prime Minister your point is
that the Judiciary has got too much
power
but what you want to do and this is
again from your critics and there are a
lot of them and like again to repeat
they're not just people on the
opposition this is you know that voices
across the across the Divide here on
this they say what you're pushing for is
a form of autocratic rule where the one
remaining check imbalance on your power
as prime minister is just evaporated and
you ultimately can then determine judge
selection you can determine what laws
pass or don't pass you become the
overriding autocratic leader as they
have in many countries where there are
genuine autocracies of the kind that you
talked about in 2012 in that speech you
keep preparing these these shiblets and
these these absurdities I made Israel
the most liberal country
among the most liberal countries on the
planet I liberalize its economy it
turned it from a straight jacketed
socialist economy to a free market
economy that benefited the entire people
I brought in investments into the Arab
sector more than all the previous
governments combined uh very proud of
the fact that the leader of the gay cell
in the likud my party I nominated to be
the speaker of the knesset the third
highest position in the country and he
was elected not because he's gay he was
elected because he's very good but
that's the liberal position that I've
always espoused and espoused now to try
to paint me as some third world autocrat
is ridiculous I believe in the balance
I'm a classic Democrat with a small deer
I don't want to get into trouble with my
American friends but I'm I'm a a classic
believer in the balance between the
three branches of government that's is
what ensures democracy and it's been
thrown off balance in Israel we have to
bring it back it will not give any power
I do not select what happens when I do
not select the judges in fact there will
be selected by uh by a composite
committee it's not important right now
but the majorities minorities they all
have their place in there so this is
complete falsehood what are the
concessions you're going to make from
the current bill to appease those who
say what you're doing is taking it from
one extreme Pendulum In Your Eyes the
most the most important thing the most
important thing is indeed to restrain
the power of the parliament to strike
down any decisions that the Supreme
Court makes I think the Supreme Court
deserves its place under the sun its
powers but it just has to be there are
no checks and balances right now in
Supreme Court power so you want to get
some checks and balances on that but you
don't want to eliminate checks and
balances on the uh but you want to stop
the Supreme Court from interfering in
any no no no no it's called against
basic laws which form the Constitutional
framework if you will you don't have a
Constitution Day no well the the Supreme
Court argues that we do already or the
the founder the Supreme former Supreme
Court president said that the basic laws
that have been enacted form a
constitutional framework so that those
in any case those laws in my opinion
have to be protected uh the Supreme
Court can't challenge them but it can
challenge other laws and the question is
what is the majority that is required in
the Supreme Court to strike down the law
that's I won't get into the the weeds
but what they're going to do surely the
Supreme Court they will try and strike
down this so so what do you do as a
prime minister that wants to do this if
the Supreme Court exercises what it
believes to be its right to strike down
your bill well I think that there's a
it's never happened before that the
Supreme Court strikes down basic law
this is a basic law and I don't think
they're about to do it and I hope they
never had such a direct attack on their
Authority it's not well then the
question is should they be able to to
judge that to you know that's a question
but it seems that the people of Israel
who are protesting every week and all
these eminent people who are commenting
about this they prefer the current
situation to one where the power moves
to the Prime Minister it always it
doesn't move to the Prime Minister
that's got nothing to do with it the
Prime Minister gets known to politicians
yeah well then you have to ask yourself
if that were the case I don't see any
democracy that has such extreme powers
of the Supreme Court as in Israel
there's no such democracy so are they
not democracies are they dictatorships
of course not they're perfect when you
are trying to take some power away from
any branch of government and in this
case from the Judiciary they don't want
to take it away right now you have a
situation where 15 unelected members of
the Supreme Court effectively govern
Israel they can decide things that
affect our military our economy our
Foreign Relations our battle with
terrorism is that right is that
Democratic no it's not Democratic you
want to correct it Israel is democratic
in the sense that you vote for a
government but when you vote for a
government you want that government to
govern right now the powers of that
government to govern are severely
restricted by a supreme court that has
more Powers than any other in any other
democracy on Earth you don't say that
those other democracies are somehow
tainted are somehow not Democratic
because they've they have a better
balance of power and trying to balance
it is difficult got you that you can see
how difficult it is right I don't deny
it and I understand the concerns of
those who are generally generally
worried about the future of Israel but
so am I and I would not let Israel
become less Democratic I wanted to be
more you've always been a politician
strikes me who's got an instinct for
what the people are thinking you must be
aware the scale of this is like nothing
you've ever had to deal with in any of
your terms of office any Israeli Prime
Minister you this is unprecedented for
you and there comes a point when if
you're just going to keep pushing up
against this gigantic ever-growing Hill
of opposition including you know members
of your own government who said they
should we should stop this and negotiate
what is your response to that well you
know I was the first one to call foreign
even though I was in a curious position
because they told me you can't deal with
the the actual uh workings of the bill
so I didn't I actually didn't but I did
call on the opposition to join the
Coalition the government to discuss
reaching some kind of cop compromise and
I've called for three months and they
haven't come so you ask yourself and
when they say let's halt it I said you
just wasted three months why did you
come in and talk get into the room start
saying what your concerns are like the
ones you raised you will uh our people
will give their responses we can I think
we can figure out a middle way that will
be I think Successful by the way I still
hope that will happen remember that the
bill that is now in in Parliament as we
speak is uh is is one component just one
component it really Deals Only with the
selection but you know how big it is
blown you went to see Richie soon like
British prime minister yesterday and in
their readout of your meeting it spoke
about the desire to save Israeli
democracy curacy in yours I'll read the
exact word he said the importance of
upholding the Democratic Values underpin
our relationship including in the
proposed judicial reforms in Israel but
in in the statement from your office
didn't mention that why well because we
spoke for about an hour and the the
Prime Minister indeed raised that issue
where prime minister Rishi it was uh
there's a debate in my in my team
whether it was 45 seconds or 47 seconds
out of the hour so yes he did raise it
you're quite right I don't deny it but I
think it's sort of it's become a
perfunctory thing you sort of have to
say it because people are oppressing
they're BDS people they're oppressing it
they're uh you know it's become a
political hot potato in Israel so uh the
the the opponents have their supporters
here and they're pressing on the various
governments I understand that and look
people don't necessarily get into the
details of it but I do and the American
president has also said the same thing
Joe Biden yes he's also said that to you
yeah sure I spoke to him the other day
on the phone what did he say to you well
first of all we spoke about Iran of
course and I'll come to that and a lot
and but he raised that and I assured him
what I assured you that Israel was Will
and all is and will remain a demand it's
a worrying time for Israel with America
because For the First Time In polling
history a majority of Democrats in
America now have more sympathy for
Palestinians than they do for Israelis
it's been 11 Point swing in the last
year alone that must concern you and
what also must concern you more people
aged 18 to 29 now view more sympathy
with Palestinians than they do Israelis
what's your response to that well I I
think I've looked at other polls but you
can never
you can never deny the the the the the
alliance between Israel and America is
takes the majority of Americans uh to
support Israel and they do they do
consistently that's going to concern you
hasn't it that Paul you know you look at
it and you say one thing uh you know
America is changing not Visa V Israel
America is changing Visa via America but
one of the reasons people have often
said that well yeah but America is
changing fees of the America and
therefore it changes vis-a-vis Israel
but I think the main bulk of American of
the American public by the way across
the political Spectrum were a wide wide
uh birth of the political Spectrum
support Israel because they see Israel
as but not representing not Democrats
right but not Democrat supporters and no
The Young Ones 18 to 29. well there's
there there's a question of where that
goes and whether this pendulum doesn't
swing back you know one of the reasons
is they they cite a lot of them
apparently your very close relationship
with Donald Trump they think that you
really pivoted to him you describe him
as a greatest friend Israel's ever had
in the White House I said Israel I had
no greater friend than the White House
that's true because he did some very
good things he moved the embassy to
Jerusalem recognize Jerusalem as our
Capital recognize our sovereignty in the
Golan Heights and went out of this
disastrous uh the Iran deal nuclear deal
that would have paved Iran's path with
gold to nuclear weapons so yes I
appreciate it but I I always approach
American Presidents whether it's uh did
you take sides too much with Trump not
at all I never took signs you're lying
yourself too much I didn't align myself
with anyone it didn't come in as a as a
Republican or a Democrat I came in as an
Israeli and I have close friends
among both sides of the aisle Joe Biden
with whom I often disagree by the way
some I disagreed with Trump too but I
try to tell them we should go to well he
wasn't happy when you when you tweeted
your congratulations to President Biden
winning the election maybe not but what
I was but he was extremely on if you
don't mind me I don't want to use a
profanity in front of you but he he was
her on tape saying that it was the
ultimate betrayal he hadn't spoken to
you since and bleep him he said about
you he then added BB is bb bb didn't
want to make peace never did right well
I did actually with his help we made a
breakthrough of Peace the Abraham
Accords with four Arab states it's a
turning point in history and if I came
back it's to do two things came back
into office because as you know it's not
walking in a Rose Garden to be the prime
minister of Israel at any time and
especially this time the reason I came
back is to do two things one block Iran
Iran's quest for nuclear weapons that
aims to destroy my country and threaten
every other country and the second thing
is to expand the historic Abraham
Accords the Peace Accords which and and
the Arab Israeli conflict and I believe
that I can do both and that's what I'm
here for but look I've dealt with
president have you spoken to Donald
Trump since since then he wrote me a
note what did he say
you congratulated me on my victory did I
yeah so have you made peace have you
spoken on the phone I didn't never made
War I mean he might be back in the white
house I've always look I have to tell
you I I have Joe Biden has been a
personal friend for over 40 years and
I've disagreed with him Donald Trump has
been a great friend and I've often
disagreed with him uh not often but
sometimes and the same happened with
other American Presidents I represent
the people of Israel a people who for
three thousand years actually 3 500
years is trying to survive and revive
itself in our ancient Homeland and we
did it doesn't go without problems as
you can see it doesn't grow without
debate Israel is fiercely Democratic
Fierce debates but I believe that we
have that my mission is to assure that
Israel is sufficiently strong militarily
economically diplomatically to defend
itself against the likes of Iran how did
you feel when you want to wipe us off
the planet when it come to Iran one
moment how did you feel about Donald
Trump having dinner with Kanye West and
the white supremacist Nick
I
think it's a big mistake it's wrong it's
wrong from every point of view how
damaging is it when someone with Kanye
West's following
suddenly seems to go Rogue anti-semitic
in the way that he did
my father was a great historian and a
story of anti-Semitism it goes back
about 2500 years as a sort of a doctrine
that keeps changing but basically people
say there's trouble in the world I want
to blame the Jews we have a setback here
or a setback there blame the Jews the
Communists say the Jews are the
capitalists the capitalists say the Jews
are the Communists blame the Jews so you
know that's a deep-seated pattern it
should not be continents it should not
be accepted it should be rebuked and
condemned and that's what I do and I
don't care I don't care where it comes
from or from whom
let's talk about Ukraine briefly if we
may I interviewed Governor Ron DeSantis
the Florida governor a few days ago and
he said that Vladimir Putin is a war
criminal and should be held account for
his crimes do you share that view
well I think that I share the view that
Ukraine the Ukraine war is a horrible
horrible uh tragedy that it should be
if I can do anything to help stop it I
will and I'll I'll refrain from saying
more because I might be in a position
might be in a position to help stop it
one day have you been asked I know you
were asked at the start to try and
mediate perhaps have you been asked
again
I haven't been asked officially
but I received unofficial approaches
from
supposedly from both sides I don't want
to say more than that at the time I
wasn't the Prime Minister I said there's
one prime minister at the time and I'm
not going to jump in and if the
opportunity
arises where there's a realistic chance
that I can help stop this tragedy this
horror horror there's no other word then
I'll do it but it wasn't a legal
Invasion wasn't it I mean it broke every
international law it's not the question
the question is where is the uh you know
what is it that you can do
uh to to stop this harm and you know as
long as there's a glimmer of a chance
that I can I'll I'll keep that
live or alive
Iran now can enrich uranium to 84 Purity
which clearly is a dangerous situation
not least for Israel
um they might see what they perceive to
be from what they've read and heard and
unchecked Israel government packed with
what many people view as extremists as a
well as a threat as a threat to them
so okay well let me just put that too
because people have said that well they
say a lot of silly things I mean this is
silly Israel is a no this has come from
Israelis who fear that that may send the
wrong message too well I think that's
nonsense I mean I think all Israelis are
united in seeing the danger of a nuclear
Iran all Israelis understand that at
least I understand that it's my
responsibility as the leader of the one
and only Jewish state which Iran's calls
for its Annihilation to do everything in
our power to stop it uh and Iran should
know that I
uh and Israel will do everything we can
to stop it it's got nothing to do with
the composition of the government it's
got everything to do with the
composition of our history and the fact
that they're calling for our destruction
Rishi sunak uh said again in the readout
from your meeting our governments will
continue to work closely together to
push back against aggression from Iran
and manage the risk of nuclear
proliferation but in reality what can
someone like Rishi sunak on behalf of
Britain do to help you in this situation
I think first of all it's important to
say it I think it's important also to
apply economic pressures uh I I think
the combination of crippling economic
sanctions and a credible military threat
can hold back Iran's nuclear Ambitions I
don't think without a credible military
threat you're not going to stop Iran
just as you the only thing that stopped
Saddam Hussein was a credible military
action on our part the only thing that
stopped
Syria
or rather
from developing nuclear weapons is a
credible military action on our part
Gaddafi feared a credible military
action on the part of the U.S so he gave
up his nuclear weapons North Korea
didn't so it has now nuclear weapons
that can cover half of Asia and very
soon perhaps the United States
Iran is 50 times more dangerous than
North Korea and we must do everything
and I must do everything to prevent it
from having nuclear weapons what is
required from the International
Community
sanctions strong sanctions from the
United States and from Israel
a credible military threat final
question prime minister there have been
88 Palestinians and 15 Israelis killed
so far this year it's the highest rate
of deaths in two decades many are saying
that a lot of this is down to
itscendiary rhetoric from some of your
right-wing members of your government
and they particularly cite bezel
smotherstridge who earlier had called
for the segregation and Maternity Ward
so Arab and Jewish newborns would be
separated at Birth he's now in charge of
the Civil administration of the Occupy
West Bank last week he said who was the
first Palestinian King what language do
the Palestinians have was there ever a
Palestinian currency is there a
Palestinian history or culture nothing
there is no such thing as a Palestinian
people that's not helpful to anything is
it uh I think that there are a lot of
statements that he made previously that
he uh
walked away from and somebody said to
her were not accurate in any case
they're part of my government but
they're part of my government and I uh I
decide policy distance yourself from
comments like that there are many
comments anybody called for the
Palestinian town of awara to be white of
course of course not of course
totally unacceptable he corrected
wait a minute be fair to him about I
don't know if it was 20 minutes later or
uh 30 minutes later or whatever or a few
hours later he said
I was misunderstood that's not what I
meant we don't believe he doesn't
believe it by the way I know him uh got
to work with him now a few months we
don't believe in Collective punishment I
go after the terrorists I go after those
who support the terrorists but I don't
believe in Collective punishment I also
think that you should know that the the
rise of Palestinian terrorism and
there's a consequences the the
fatalities that you're talking about
actually happened in the previous
government it doubled the number of
shooting incidents Drive downs and other
things that are involved in terrorism
came from the Palestinian side and the
weakness that we have here is the
weakness of the Palestinian Authority
that doesn't send its Security Forces to
stop the terrorists and therefore we
have to do it and what we are trying to
do right now is calm things down put a
if you will uh
put some kind of mechanism in place that
we're trying to do with the Palestinian
Authority and with others to stop the
violence members of your government
saying stuff like that is unbelievably
in Century well that comment on that
Village is absolutely right and he
walked away from it very quickly but his
comments saying there's no such thing as
Palestinians well he has that view uh I
think do you have that v no I think I
think there wasn't a Palestinian people
in the 19th century clearly
I think it galvanized their National
Consciousness galvanized in the 20th
century and the question is will it hold
or into the future that's something that
has to be seen uh but I I think they're
there they're they're definitely you
know living among us and we have to live
among them the problem we have with them
is that they say you're not going to
live among us the problem the reason
this conflict persists now for a hundred
years is because the Palestinians led by
irresponsible leaders are resolutely
opposed to a Jewish state in any
boundary so it doesn't make it no one
succeeded previous governments very
left-wing government generous
governments you know unbelievably
concessionary governments they gave
everything nothing helped because they
are not interested in a territorial
resolution they're interested in the
dissolution of the one and only Jews so
far this year so far this year six times
as many Palestinians have died as
Israelis that's just a fact well do you
want to compare what happened in uh I'm
not just saying this year you want to
come you want to compare other conflicts
uh include Global I'm saying this
historical yeah well because what
happens is that they start shooting the
Israelis uh they have we go after the
terrorists the terrorists hide inside
terrorist strongholds and to get to them
we have to fight other terrorists most
of them by the way are combatants that
is terrorists who are who have been hit
but in the crossfire that is there I
wouldn't judge the justice of a battle
by the number of casualties on either
side because you'd be in very very shaky
historical ground uh and you know that
very well I know you've got to go to get
a plan uh you're on Tick Tock I'm on
Tick Tock yeah a lot of calls now for
people to ban Tick Tock what's your view
for Israel and will you come off it no
no I haven't looked into it though
you're not worried about the Chinese
well harvesting data for you and all the
Israelis who use tick tock well I'll
tell you what since you raise it I'll
look into it thank you prime minister
good to see you thank you thank you